I phones are in the news a lot lately
thanks to apples ongoing battle with the
FBI in 2014 Apple introduced a security
feature that keeps others including the
federal government from snooping around
your phone but that security feature
could also end up erasing all your data
if say you're too drunk to remember your
passcode or your kid get to hold up your
phone here's some tips and keep that
from happening first back up your phone
the simplest way to do this is using
iTunes it allows you to choose what
content you save and even gives you the
option to encrypt your data which is
great if you have things you want to
keep private like those late-night dance
sessions yeah let's keep it spread if
you're not an iTunes fan then you can
back up your phone over the cloud the
easiest way to do this is to use I club
just go to your settings to find the
iCloud tab you can even set iCloud to
back up automatically if you backed up
with iTunes simply plug in your phone
and fire up the app it should
automatically walk you through how to
erase and restore your backup data if it
doesn't just go to file devices restore
and select the backup you want to use
for those who use iCloud turn on your
phone and follow the instructions you'll
have to sign into Wi-Fi then into iCloud
and pick which backup you want to use
now you'll always have your to step
safely stored and protected so get down